i had a question for you dude i'm for
one i'm taking a dookie right now i
apologize for that
dang bubba
but at least your uh efficiency
you know you're doing efficiency brother
and i don't like it
but i respect it
but uh so my dad had just recently
passed
and
he was an amputee and had a fake leg
bruh
i
want to save that leg
take it to ball games and everything
else and chug beers out of it
you think that's a good idea or what
look i appreciate you calling man and um
this is crazy we're just talking about
this
and so
you know i have a little bit of
experience with extra limb
and i'm going to say this man first of
all
yeah you got to do something with it
you know put it to use man that thing
that damn that tibia or whatever that
[ __ ] got magic in it
you know it's the last piece of your
father you have
you know maybe hanging in the garage and
you know like some people hang a tennis
ball so they know when to stop the car
hang that [ __ ] right there
every time you you know the windshield
of your dodge neon or whatever hits that
thing you're gonna remember pops
and you're gonna stop the car stop for
pops it could be a little moniker you
know every time stop for pops bam hit
that leg
that's beautiful bro
or put that [ __ ] in it get some damn
light some candles around that [ __ ] and
ask it questions
that [ __ ] has got powers in it bro
you out here chugging beers out of it
like a [ __ ] homeless kid dude are you
out of your mind
that's a piece of your damn father
and you're doing business calls and [ __ ]
come on bro
i mean is it you know
your dad lost his [ __ ] leg
so you could sit around and do [ __ ]
calls
but i don't think so baby
i don't think so
you know what that makes me want to do
that makes me want to vape on this
[ __ ] plant
that's what you get boy
take care it's the last piece of your
father you know how much i i'd love to
have a piece of my dad
i'd love to have a damn earlobe of my
father's or something
you know when you out here with a whole
damn limb bruh
then you [ __ ] sipping damn uh
blue moons out that [ __ ] or whatever
get your life together bro
get off the [ __ ] and get out in the
yard and [ __ ] hit dingers with that
[ __ ]
you know drive down the street at night
and hit people's mailboxes
give your dad a [ __ ] life bro
a fake leg never dies man that and a
fake leg never dies bruh
that's is it's halfway between ghosts
and human man
and you got that [ __ ]
you know sneak that [ __ ] into the
olympics dude
get a job running the torch and then
surprise him
like that [ __ ] at the top
and run that bit you know run it to
wherever
damn iowa you know cedar rapids run that
[ __ ] over there
throw you know have let the kids have a
sleepover and just hum that [ __ ] into
the tent in the middle of the night
[ __ ] them up bro
but do something man do something
special
but live a little man that's what i tell
you to be real honest with you i'm sorry
for getting angry at you
but somebody has to tell you something
man
maybe that's why he left that bro
she could get a kick in the ass and get
some motivation going
gang
baby hope you enjoyed that video and you
can watch another and you can watch this
one you can watch this one different
options different choices some guy just
brings you one option not this guy
two options
watch one this one or this one